pour parler de cette histoire guy st
jacques ancien ambassadeur du canada en
chine est avec nous ce saint jacques
bonsoir bonjour monsieur roy
malheureusement ce n'est pas la première
fois que ça arrive que des gens très
connus en chine quand il critique
ouvertement le régime où là c'est encore
pire elle accuse un personnage important
de l'avoir violée disparaissent parce
que c'est ce qu'il faut comprendre
qu'elle 1 quelle est votre analyse à ce
moment ci mais moi je pensais que ces
deux régimes qui essaie de la faire
taire par tous les moyens puis peut-être
pour deux raisons d'abord on approche
des jeux olympiques et est ce que les
chinois qing sur mac c'est que si elle
parle en fait que le scandale
s'élargissent parce que je serais pas
surpris qu'il ait d'autres cas sachant
la façon dont les athlètes chinois sont
élevés et préparer pour les compétitions
internationales et d'autre part
c'est une année importante pour le parti
communiste chinois monsieur si jean ping
espère que le parti va entériner un
troisième mandat lors de son congrès qui
vont avoir lieu là approcher un acteur
et il faut qu'il donne l'image d'un
parti qui est pure où les dirigeants
sont sans reproche et donc de permettre
à cette histoire d'être
face à enquête ça risquerait de ternir
l'image du portishead je pense qu'il n'y
pas c'est que les betas communiquer ça
calmerait le jeu et que les gens le
pensent à autre chose mais là ça prend
de la place et je passe que la machine
de propagande chinoise a été prise par
surprise parce que c'est cousu de fil
blanc son texte qu'elle a publiés en za
non mais finalement j'ai pas été violée
et je mange tout va bien je me repose
c'est cousu de fil blanc personnes
croient à ça mais là les chinois sont
devant quand même une fronde importante
la wta qui dit on aurait pu jouer chez
vous comme vous dites les olympiques qui
arrive est ce qu'est ce qu'ils peuvent
faire ils vont encore une fois ce n'est
pas la première fois qu'ils font ça
habituellement aussi les ont l'habitude
de faire des menaces et dans ce cas
aussi il prend le maquis et s ortec la
wta dirait bombay on a tellement
d'enjeux économiques parlent de
centaines de millions de dollars qu'on
va penser les profs battu puis monsieur
ça et minent le président d'association
persiste et là avec toutes les vedettes
internationales
ça crée des vagues
je ne pense pas que les chinois
permettent une enquête mais il a tout le
moins ils vont prendre organiser une
apparition au montrer qu'elle est
qu'elle est bien mais en espérant que ça
va pas aller plus loin je pense que là
c'est le moment opportun pour je dirais
aussi pour les gouvernements étrangers
de s'intégrer de s'intéresser à la
question est de demander des
explications parce que sinon si on joue
le jeu de la chine la chine puis on ne
réagit pas - l'encouragent à continuer
avec ce genre de comportement est il cet
homme qu'elle accuse l'accusé parce que
c'est des revenus mais qu'elle accuse je
gare aux lilas zinc ali
je le disais il était très puissant est
ce que la chaîne pourrait pas le lâcher
lui dire bon mais très bien faisant un
procès non
il pourrait faire ça mais en même temps
un nouveau ça risquerait de soulever un
débat est-ce qu'il ya d'autres corps
comme ça et lui ou des gens puissants se
permettent d'utiliser
leur position pour obtenir ce qu'ils
veulent dans la force l'appui avoir un
comportement tout à fait répréhensible
et puis je pense que c'est ça que
probablement que les leadership chinois
est très inquiet et dites-moi qui saint
jacques dans le cas du grand patron jack
mme haddad d'ali baba très riche qui
était on disait l'homme le plus riche de
chine lui aussi a eu des ennuis lui
aussi a disparu entre guillemets donc
c'est une si tu veux vraiment une arme
que le régime encore en 2021 emploi
les yeux car en fait il apparaît de plus
en plus parce que en fait se regardent
au cours des six derniers mois la chine
on voulait envoyer un message très
puissant à l'endroit de les grandes
compagnies de technologie ou des copines
à le domaine de l'éducation comme il y
aura bientôt en leur disant si vous
appuyez politique du parti vous allez
payer un prix plus aussi en leur disant
en amenant cette notion de prospérité
commune en disant vous devez contribuer
à distribuer la richesse que vous avez
accumulé il était aussi très inquiet de
l'influencé des vedettes de cinéma des
grands influenceurs là aussi ils ont
arrêté quelques jours après que ça
qu'ils n'avaient pas payé leurs impôts
et tout ça c'est pour essayer de
contrôler l'idéologie parce que le
régime a l'impression parce que ma
clique les jeunes chinois sont en train
de décrocher et c'est ça la hantise du
président xi jinping et du régime
chinois c'est qu'un mandat n'est il
risque de perdre le contrôle parce que
tellement des neg alité en chine sur le
plan social sur le plat de choses et
avec une société qui est fermée que il
ya un risque touchant explose puis à
nouveau système on veut donner l'image
que seul le parti communiste peut bien
gérer la chaîne et que lui
lui la seule personne pour enfin
atteindre ce grand rêve la régénération
de la nation chinoise bon et pendant ce
temps ce bail d'une qui jongle avec une
un boycott diplomatique non pas général
des jeux de pékin mais diplomatique de
ne pas envoyer de dignitaires et
d'autres pays est ce que vous croyez
qu'on s'en va vers la wii je pense et
puis en fait ce qu'on avait dû faire il
ya un an et demi c'est invoqué la co
vivons n'est fait pour retarder des jeux
dorna et utiliser ce délai pour forcer
la chine à accepter qu'il ya une enquête
sur la situation au xinjiang de la
forcer à collaborer sur la vraie origine
de l'épidémie de la part des bides de
coved 19 maintenant c'est bien sûr on
veut pas pénaliser les athlètes mais il
faut envoyer un message on n'envoie pas
tolérer des comportements de voyous et
il devrait y avoir une entente entre les
pays occidentaux pour dire qu'aucun pays
ne va envoyer une délégation officielle
au jeu aux cérémonies d'ouverture je
pense que leurs sites gen pays
commençait à comprendre qu'on est
sérieux on va s'en reparler du sort
c'est en février on le rappelle guy st
jacques ancien ambassadeur en chine du
canada chaîne merci beaucoup de vent
parle merci merci au revoir